positive mantras don't work and they
don't work because people pick positive
mantras that they don't believe so if
you are in a studio apartment eating
rice and beans barely able to pay your
bills standing in front of a mirror and
saying I'm a millionaire I'm going to be
a millionaire someday what happens based
on Research is your brain's like uh
actually have you seen where you live
like have you seen that you've quit
every job that you've had your brain has
a great detector the mistake people make
is they pick a mantra that is the exact
opposite of the way they treat
themselves a once action
behavioral activation therapy act like
the person you say you want to be and
then maybe I'll believe you you know
instead of I love my body after trashing
your body for 20 years say I deserve to
be healthy even if you hate your body
anybody and any brain can get behind
yeah you do that's right I'm glad you're
waking up you do deserve to be healthy
now prove it let's take some actions
that show you that hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
let's learn how you can Leverage The Law
of Attraction
enjoy
so no mantras don't work if you're
picking a mantra you don't believe and
if you're picking a mantra that is the
opposite of the way you treat yourself
and the actions you take so that's
number one number two manifesting
everybody has been sold a bill of goods
about manifesting
if you make a vision board with your uh
house on the ocean or you at the stock
exchange ringing the bell and that's all
that you have on it
science says that that vision board will
become a source of
profound discouragement
because over time as you sit there and
stare at your dream house or you ringing
the bell at NASDAQ and nothing in your
life changes
you start to feel further and further
and further away from what you want
which makes you feel further and further
discouraged which means you're less and
less motivated to even begin working on
it like the hardest part for everybody
is to start and the reason why is not
only the patterns of procrastination and
anxiety and stuff that you get trapped
in but it's also because your goals feel
so far away that you don't believe that
just starting is going to even chip away
at it and so number one because it
sounds like I just contradicted myself
yes you need to have something like a
beach house or the NASDAQ Bell or the
business you're starting or the love
affair of your life or the family you've
always envisioned or the health that
you've always dreamed about absolutely
swing for the fences what do you want it
to look like 10 years from now
but when it comes to manifesting based
on science I want you to think as
manifesting as a bridge
manifesting is a bridge that's made of
bricks between you
and the thing that you dream about
and what you do when you manifest is you
don't manifest where the bridge is going
you manifest the bricks
so a great example is a marathon so
let's say that you've never run a day in
your life but your bucket list is to
complete the London Marathon
yes you can put on your vision board
a photograph of a runner crossing the
London Marathon you can even put the
dream that you have in terms of the the
number that you want the time to be okay
but you better put a runner in the rain
up there
you better put an alarm clock that says
4 30 in the morning because that's what
time you're going to have to get up in
order to get your training runs in you
better put a runner that's gripping
their leg like this when they get a
muscle cramp you better put up uh you
know a vision of you at Mile 13 and your
earbuds run out and you still got two
more miles to go
visualization is the bricks and so what
I want you to do when you visualize is
instead of visualizing ah the marathon I
did it I was amazing and then you open
up you're like okay and I still have not
even bought a pair of sneakers
that's not happening but that was a fun
little exercise no what you do is you
literally visualize walk into the store
and get sneakers
call your friend who runs and ask for
advice
oh my God that's me on my first training
run I've only gone 30 seconds and I'm
out of breath oh there I am running
three miles in the rain and I feel proud
of myself because I've actually gone out
in the rain oh there I am saying uh no
to my friends I can't go out tonight
because I didn't get my run in but I'm
gonna go on my big run alone that like
you visualize the annoying irritating
amazing things I'm sure people look at
you all the time with your extraordinary
success Steven and are like how'd you do
it how'd you do it and
like do you know how many things I
missed out on do you know how many like
how like the amount of work that nobody
wants to do because they're not thinking
about it
is extraordinary that's the bridge
anybody is capable of achieving anything
I actually believe that because I think
human beings are designed to change
you're capable of breaking any pattern
you are capable of getting control of
your health you're capable of launching
a business you're capable of making
millions of dollars you're capable of
healing your trauma of finding love of
doing absolutely anything that you put
your mind to
as long as you are willing to do the
work for it and as long as you give up
your timeline
because I do believe
that people who put in the work get
rewarded
but you just might not get rewarded when
you think you're going to be and it
might not be the reward that you thought
you were gonna get is that the case in
your life it's always the case
and that's why I always have Big Dreams
because I have learned time and time and
time and time again especially in
entrepreneurial Ventures
that you put this huge flag out there
you write the business plan you set the
goals and then you put your head down
and you put in the work
and you ride the wave and you have the
disappointments and you spend the late
nights and you have the Heartbreak and
the heartache and then things change and
then you think this didn't work out and
I got betrayed and why didn't they
recognize me and damn it I've worked
hard and now I got to start all over and
you have all of that but if you keep
going
and you keep going
eventually you will look up one day and
be like holy
this
is exactly
what I was meant to do and what I was
meant to discover yeah my business plan
said I was supposed to go over here
and I ended up over here because this is
what I was supposed to do but without
this business plan I never would have
gotten started
the business plan was but a DOT on the
map of my life
connecting me to where I meant to go
you know I think one of the most
extraordinary things that has happened
to me in this past year especially now
that I have this real partnership with
myself
where I have a
level of trust
that through my attitude through my
actions through a sense of faith
that
it's going to turn out
that even when things are really hard I
still believe deep in my core
that through my attitude and my actions
it's going to be okay
that I have within me the power to ride
the ups and downs and to come out on the
other side of it
and
you know I think that we've all had the
experience Stephen of being able to look
backwards and say whoa you know I
wouldn't ever wish the experience that I
had back and forth great on anybody
but without that experience
I would not be able to help the amount
of people that I help
I would not be able to understand trauma
as a lived experience and inside and out
and at a layer that's so deep because it
is an experience that I had in my life
without 25 years of struggling with
anxiety without having two kids that
have struggled with anxiety I would not
know what I know about anxiety and be
able to help people including my own
children
uh I would not without having made
mistakes uh with my kids and their
anxiety be able to tell parents do not
do this because I did this and it made
my kids anxiety worse and I didn't even
know
and so I can see you know I can see how
everything from you know working as a
public defender to being a legal
commentator for CNN to the number of
stages that I've been on to the number
of people that I've helped I can see how
all of that comes together
to help me do what I need to do in this
moment
and I think one of the most powerful
things that you can cultivate when you
cultivate partnership with yourself
is being able every single day to have a
level of trust in your life
in the magic of things in yourself to
know that this moment right now is also
a DOT on the map of your life and 5 10
20 years from now you will look back on
this moment
and you will know exactly why this
happened
and why it happened is it was preparing
you for something
it was giving you a skill or an
experience or some wisdom or a
relationship that you're gonna need for
something extraordinary that's coming
and when you believe that it gives you
the strength to face absolutely anything
rule number two is Manifest effortlessly
with Rhonda Byrne what's the difference
between I guess the still level of
needing to master your craft though
right like you became a great producer
and a director and creator that doesn't
come after two days of not working on
your craft right because you worked on
your craft for a decade or two until you
had the skill set the knowledge the
wisdom to them yeah put down what you
needed to
doing things
is the thing because if being effortless
doesn't mean you're not doing things
what it means is there's no effort in
what you're doing
so it's it's so you're still doing
things but it's effortless like you were
still working up but it was effortless
and so because the minute you feel like
you're struggling that's the mind and
that's the ego stepped in and then it's
not flowing you know and and people will
find when they're struggling you know
there's that goes wrong and then that
goes wrong and that goes wrong and so
you still do things and I still did all
of those things like before the secret I
did everything with effort full effort
one thousand percent hard work full
effort yeah total queen of effort
and you were lacking and you were
lacking abundance
you were lacking big results and yeah
yeah and so now I do like I I sat down
to do this book this book was absolutely
effortless really oh oh my gosh
absolutely and the most effortless book
that I have written for sure I mean
amazing really amazing and so when I was
writing to see I wrote The Secret in two
and a half weeks two and a half weeks
because it just like wow because I'd
made the documentary I'd done all these
practices I knew what I wanted to share
all of the things that I wanted to share
in the secret and so I mean we've spent
you know about six weeks in the editing
process of it but it just came like a
rush and that two and a half weeks was
effortless and when I did this book it
was effortless and I and there have been
books that I've gone to right where has
been a lot of effort really you know
yeah yeah and I and I just have to stop
because I remember I wrote a book and I
never published it and it was all effort
and it was enforcing it you were yeah
forcing it and so then what you're
writing about is you're just writing a
whole lot of recycled stuff that the
mind is turning up and you are not
receiving things from Beyond the mind
and you want to have things beyond the
mind
you know that's why when you when you're
an athlete and that flow and everything
that's because the mind has stopped it's
gone to the background and now you're
beyond the mind and when you're beyond
the mind oh anything's possible rule
number three is use the power of
sankalpa the Deepak Chopra these days of
course everyone's talking about
intention fulfillment of Desire
uh manifestation
Etc so I thought I'd share with you what
uh some of the wisdom Traditions have
taught us about manifestation
and
from their teachings of non-duality we
can see that all manifestation is really
a differentiation of pure consciousness
which is infinitely creative
and is infinite and formless and
irreducible and
Timeless and spaceless and unimaginable
and inconceivable
but when intention is orchestrated from
that level
then it organizes its own fulfillment
that level is also called sankalpa
or a combination of dharana dhyan
samadhi but let me explain it in simple
English
so here are the six steps I think number
one a certain outcome is intended
number two the intention is specific and
definite
the person is certain about what he or
she wants
number three little or no attention is
paid to the details of the physiological
processes involved indeed paying
attention to the details inhibits the
flow of the impulses of intelligence
that produce the outcome slowing down or
preventing success
in other words the person takes an
attitude of non-interference nor
resistance to existence
number four the person expects a result
and has confidence in the outcome
there is no anxious attachment or
grasping to a result however if you are
anxious about falling asleep for example
that prevents the very outcome you
desire worry uncertainty and doubt are
the three primary obstacles that prevent
us from making
efficient use of the power contained in
sankalpa or intention the power is still
there but we turn it against itself when
we interfere in other words when you
doubt that a desire will come true
essentially you're sending out a
self-defeating intention which the field
computes field of Consciousness computes
is canceling out your first desire
number five there's a self-referring
feedback loop involved in other words
every fulfilled intention teaches you
how to fulfill the next intention even
better when the result occurs it
confirms the power of intention at a
conscious level
it increases confidence and makes
success
stronger
okay so see the intention water the seed
and when the season is right the
intention will manifest and the effect
will be reinforcing
this change is doubt so when you do this
you know when you have some kalban you
detach from the outcome this changes
doubt to certainty
people whose desires don't come true
also experience feedback but it
reinforces failure
okay so feedback
is always a result of
any intention whether it succeeds or not
will give you feedback
and you'll notice that
that intention if it doesn't succeed is
because of resistance to existence and
absence of flow
finally number six at the end of the
process there's no doubt that the
outcome was obtained by a definite
conscious process that extends beyond
the individual to a larger reality for
some this is God others Providence
but in the non-dual view it is the self
the absolute self
the absolute self not the self-image
so I try to use more scientific terms
um and uh the one that I'm using right
now is the Consciousness field which is
a Consciousness energy field
but I don't think we should discard any
of the other more traditional spiritual
names in all cases the material world is
an expression of an unmanifest
overriding intelligence that responds to
human desire
the six steps that I just shared with
you are the most important
characteristic of inner intelligence it
has organizing power built into it
organizing power built into it the
organizing part is the link that
connects intention and result
without it there could be no cause or
effect
the quantum soup would remain chaotic
since without organizing part there can
be no patterns no orderliness no natural
laws no physical structures or
biochemical processes also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is use positive
affirmations daily with Jack Canfield if
you have a goal you want to achieve in
the year ahead or if you find it hard to
stay focused on doing what you need to
do to create the life you want keep
watching this video
because I'm about to share one of my
most powerful successful practices that
I have used to achieve my biggest goals
in life and if you commit to using this
practice every single day for the next
12 months I guarantee you will
experience huge shifts and you'll
achieve goals you may not think are
possible right now and that success
practice is
drum roll
Daily Affirmations
now an affirmation as you probably
already know is a positive statement
that describes your goals as already
having been achieved it only takes a few
minutes but if you say your affirmation
out loud a few times every day with a
clear and focused mind while also
feeling the feelings you'd be feeling if
you'd already achieved that goal you'll
find it so much easier for you to keep
your goals top of mind and stay focused
and motivated as you work toward making
your dreams a reality so today I'd like
to teach you how to create your own
daily affirmation practice that you can
use to more effortlessly more quickly
and more efficiently accomplish your
goals and manifest your ideal vision of
the next 12 months ahead but first I'd
like to tell you about when I first
experienced the powerful the power of
affirmations in my life and when I was
in my 20s I had a mentor named Debbie
Clement Stone he was worth 600 million
dollars and he challenged me to set a
goal that was so far beyond my current
circumstances that it would literally
Astound me if I achieved it now I still
had a lot of self-esteem doubt back then
so it wasn't until a few years later
that I actually decided to put his
wisdom to the test I set myself the
challenge of making a jump from earning
around 25 000 a year to making a hundred
thousand a year or more the first thing
I did was to create an affirmation for
myself which went like this God is my
infinite Supply and large sums of money
come to me quickly and easily under the
grace of God as I'm happily and easily
earning spending and investing a hundred
thousand a year
next I created a huge replica of a
hundred thousand dollar bill which I
taped to the ceiling above my bed so
when I woke up every morning I would see
this hundred thousand dollar bill up
there and then immediately reminded me
to remember to repeat my affirmation to
myself and then I would visualize what I
would be enjoying if I were living a one
hundred thousand dollar a year lifestyle
I imagine the house I would live in the
artwork and the furniture that would be
there the car I would own the car I
would drive and what it would sound like
the vacations I would take and the
contributions of Charities I would make
I also Imagine the feelings I would
experience when I once I'd already
attained that lifestyle and you know
what not too long after that I woke up
one morning with my first hundred
thousand dollar idea I realized that if
I sold 400 000 copies of my book that
I'd written for teachers called 100 ways
to enhance self-confidence in the
classroom for which I earned a whole big
25 cents per book royalty I would earn a
hundred thousand dollar income so from
that point forward when I did my morning
affirmations and I also did it before I
went to bed at night I added the image
of my book flying off bookstore shelves
and see the whole window of a bookstore
filled with my books and I imagined the
publisher writing me a hundred thousand
dollar check now not long after a
freelance journalist approached me and
wrote an article about my work for the
National Enquirer and as a result
thousands of additional copies of my
book were sold that month and the money
making ideas just kept coming I took out
small ads and magazines and sold the
book on my own we started a little
bookstore so instead of 25 cents I'm
making three dollars a copy now I only
have to sell what 33 000 copies so
basically I'm selling this book then my
wife said you know we should sell other
books we start a little catalog so I
have my book of course we've made other
books and tapes and things that were
there back to the days of cassette tapes
and I made even more money and then the
counseling department at the University
of Massachusetts where I was a graduate
student saw my catalog it invited me to
sell books at this weekend conference
they were putting on for school
counselors Book Sales that weekend
generated more than two thousand dollars
in two days and introduced me to another
strategy I could use to achieve my
financial goal which was to become a
speaker and conduct workshops and
seminars just like I seen at the
conference and sell books in the back of
the room so I started the book regular
speaking and workshop gigs and then I
asked a friend who was doing similar
work at the time if I should charge
higher fees and he told me that he was
charging more than double what I was
being paid for the same work so I
followed this example I tripled my
speaking fees and a result of my book
sales and the income for my speaking
Goods my income that year skyrocketed
from 25
000 to over ninety two thousand now I
ended up missing my hundred thousand
dollar goal by almost eight thousand
dollars but I was still ecstatic I'd
almost quadrupled my income in less than
a year and I've made at least a six
figure income often seven figure income
every year since then now that's just
one example of how I've used
affirmations to achieve my big goals in
life now working with affirmation has
also helped me get the idea for creating
a billion dollar brand writing a New
York Times number one best selling book
actually about 47 of them and I now own
a vacation home in in about building one
in Costa Rica I own one in Maui Hawaii
for a while I live in a 6500 square foot
house in Santa Barbara So affirmations
are an extremely effective way for you
to align your subconscious mind with the
life you want to create for yourself
so how do you create an affirmation well
you start with the vision of what you
want to be do or have in your life so
what I'd like you to do is to take a
moment close your eyes right now and
answer these questions or let an image
come into your awareness to answer the
question
so the question is what is your vision
for the next 12 months of your life
[Music]
what goals do you want to accomplish
what would your life look like and feel
like once those goals are accomplished
and allow yourself to sit in the
experience of that for a moment here you
are it's a year for now you've
accomplished all your goals and you're
feeling this the success of that the joy
of that the pride of that whatever it is
just for a moment visualize what that
life would look like
and what you would be feeling if you'd
already accomplished this
foreign
[Music]
once that vision is clearly fixing your
head go ahead and open your eyes
and I want you to write down an
affirmation let me give you a little
before I went
tutoring on how to do that it's
important to remember that it's a
positive statement to describes the
experience you'll enjoy once you're in a
state of already having accomplished
that so be sure to write it in the
present tense from the perspective of
your future self who've already achieved
that goal for example I'm so happy and
grateful now that I'm working in my
dream job and doing work I love is
making a positive impact in the world so
it starts with I am as you can see I'm
describing that experience in the
present tense it's describing what my
life will be like and how I will feel
once I achieve that ambitious goal so
what's a big goal that you want to
accomplish for your life in the next 12
months and how will you feel once you've
accomplished it maybe you'll feel happy
and grateful like me or maybe you'll
feel strong and confident or Blissful
and triumphant so choose two positive
and Powerful adjectives or feeling words
that will describe your state of being
once you've achieved that goal for your
life and then write your affirmation
something like this I am so whatever the
feeling is and the feeling is now that I
have and then you state the goal as if
you've already achieved it so the
example would be
you could maybe it goes to run a
marathon this year so your affirmation
could be I'm so happy and proud that I'm
now completing my first marathon in
under four hours so be sure to make it
specific and frame it as a positive
statement as opposed to a negative
statement for example I am so overjoyed
and grateful that I'm not in a bad
marriage anymore is not going to be good
because you've got the word bad marriage
in there because it's focused on what
you don't want which is a bad marriage
so make sure stated positively for
example I'm so overjoyed and grateful
that I'm now experiencing a healthy and
loving relationship with someone who
deeply appreciates me for who I am
all right so I encourage you to write an
affirmation like this for every Big Goal
you have for yourself this year and then
repeat each of them to yourself out loud
every morning and do it again right
before you go to bed
then after you've finished your
affirmation you've said them maybe you
have three four or five of them close
your eyes and visualize yourself
experiencing the very reality you've
just describing and see the scene as if
you're looking out through your eyes as
if you're actually living in it don't
see you out there you're looking out at
the world you would see if you'd
achieved it hear the sounds you might
hear might be Applause it might be the
sound of your car the sound of the ocean
lapping up against the front of your
beachfront property and feel the
feelings that you'll feel when you
achieve that success
stronger the feelings the more powerful
the experience will be and the easier it
will be for you to keep your goals and
your vision top of Mind rule number five
is assess the results with Bob Proctor
how do you know what vibrational
frequency level you're operating at uh
because people often judge their
people judge their performance by their
productivity by their efficiency we're
not trained as you said with your
Paradigm again going back to that we're
not trained to observe our frequency and
vibration and people are not sure so if
someone's listening and watching us
today how do they know what their
vibration or their frequency is how do
they diagnose that well I think the only
way to do it is by the results you're
getting
it'll tell you right make sense see the
results do tell the truth they don't lie
Spirit manifests through its polar
opposite always we're Spiritual Beings
Spirit flows to and through us
and we'll do anything for us whatever we
ask it'll give us
and we're asking in thought
so what we want to do is take a look
what have I been thinking take a look at
your results you'll know what you're
thinking
that's how you can tell the frequency
you're on you want to start
frequencies vibration vibrations feeling
when you say I feel bad what you're
really saying is I'm not in a very good
vibration
you say I feel particularly good you're
saying I'm in a pretty good vibration
conscious awareness of vibration is
referred to as feeling
um
so I think the way to really understand
the frequency and the vibrations you're
operating on is by the results you're
getting
yeah if you're continually having
problems in all areas of your life
you're on the wrong you're in the wrong
vibration you know very low level of
vibration
and we can change it now I teach that in
the seminars I have ways of illustrating
and everything and it's important and as
people get into it
they really like it see I think when you
hear the truth you'll know it
and
I came across I don't know it came to me
I guess I was searching for a way how to
explain that
when you hear the truth you'll know it
well
there's music in this room right now
there's music in your room you may not
hear it but we know it's here
it's being broadcast it's in the room
and we don't hear it because our ears
are not operating on the frequency the
music is being broadcast on
but if we turned on a radio the radio
picks up on that frequency speeds it up
Zippo we're up on a higher frequent and
we can hear it
well
it's the receiver on the radio it picks
it up
sends it up on a higher level where you
hear it
when you hear the truth the truth
resonates with the essence of Who You
Are
and when it resonates IT sets up that
vibration it comes out on the conscious
level as knowing you just know
is no that's right yeah when you hear
the truth you'll know I know it that's
true
well that's true when you're reading
something
when a person says something to you
you hear it and you just I know that's
not true
I know that is true
resonates with the essence there is
perfection our spiritual DNA is perfect
and when we hear the truth it's like
that's the receiver
and it clicks in you know
yeah we're pretty
fascinating expressions of life you and
I and
everybody else I mean
the beautiful part is like I've studied
this like a scientist probably
more serious as the time goes on
but for 60 years starting on the 21st
this past October this is my 60th year
and I study this every day I mean this
is I'm obsessed with this
and
at one time that bothered me uh it
doesn't anymore
and so
I I just don't stop studying it and it's
so beautiful
bring that that other thing up instead
of bothered me
I used to think you hear things and you
think they're positives are negative I
hear Obsession I thought that was
negative
somebody told me I was obsessed with
something or I thought I was obsessed
and they've got a hold of Lloyd C
Douglas's book The Magnificent Obsession
and I I thought how could it be native
it was magnificent you know yeah
I got the dictionary out and I looked
the word up I don't know why I hadn't
done it before that
and it says an obsession is the
persistent disturbing preoccupation with
an often unreasonable idea
it's a magnificent just
definition
and I'm obsessed with a beautiful
concept
um
who am I that's that's the obsession and
rule number six the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is live with a
manifestation mindset with Gabby
Bernstein I love this I wrote
manifestation occurs when you shift the
dialogue turn it around change the
conversation and reach for a vibration
that feels good for you when you feel
that energy that feels good for you this
way you can clear space to share your
true gifts and intentions with the world
change your mind turn it around assume a
new energy and share your gifts
so now Bethany's greatly sharing her
gifts in that Farm Center right and now
greatly sharing her gifts with her
coaching clients because she's teaching
others how to be inspired you got that
it's amazing
so to close out my part I want to really
give you I really want to take questions
from everybody so I want to give you the
manifestation mindset qualities what are
the qualities of someone who is living
with a manifestation mindset
so the first one is that creative
capacity to think in an Innovative way
so the same way rather than canceling on
Tara I said you know what I'm going to
say a prayer
Bethany rather than thinking she could
only make money one way she just opened
up her capacity to think she could maybe
make money as a gardener the creative
capacity to think of new things to think
of New Opportunities your creative mind
will say go on that date with that guy
even though he doesn't seem like the
kind of guy you want to go on a date
with and all of a sudden that guy
becomes your husband
your creative mind is your ing your
creative mind is your spirit
your non-creative linear focused to-do
list this that this that let's make it
look like this that's your ego that
works sometimes for some things and we
need to be practical we need to look at
things but that ego without your ing is
fear it is fear it holds you back it's
small and it keeps you stuck
so we need to begin to bring in that
creative capacity to see new directions
the manifestation mind is also faithful
so it's that person who is committed to
recognizing okay you know what I have
fear everybody does
I Gabrielle Bernstein have fear I am
committed and faithful to love every one
day at a time I commit to love and the
more I commit to love the more Love Is
All I See
and so one day at a time I show up and I
say
snap that rubber band in my mind that
wasn't working I forgive myself I choose
to see this differently show me what you
got
this is my pattern moment to moment
faithfulness faithful to love become
more faithful to love and miracles than
you are to fear and lack become more
faithful to love and miracles and you
will be living in a manifestation
mindset it doesn't mean that your fears
disappear it doesn't mean that you don't
wake up every day with anxiety it
doesn't mean that it's gone immediately
but it does mean that it gets better and
better every day one day you wake up and
you say holy crap
I went through five hours this morning
without feeling anxious
I spent decades waking up anxious I
spent decades making everybody crazy
with my own anxiety and all of a sudden
one day it was gone because I tirelessly
and Faithfully committed to love and
miracles and then woke up one day and I
wasn't anxious anymore and that anxiety
has never ever come back
it never came back
gone
and that's a practice it's a commitment
and it's faithfulness so making that
Fearless commitment one day at a time to
witness your fear choose to change your
mind and pray for a miracle the miracle
is just that shift in perception the
miracle is the moment I said let's do
the show with Tara got off the show and
said I feel so energized this is a
miracle that is a miracle a miracle is
the moment that you say I'm so excited
about this date and you make a new
friend the miracle is the moment that
you choose to say I love my my the fact
that I can pay off my bills I say a
prayer and then that next day you know
what you feel good and you call in that
new job the Miracles that you feel good
the Miracles that you release
and then really groovy stuff occurs
because you're always attracting towards
you what you are putting out so if
you're vibrating at a released loving
relaxed way so much greatness can come
towards you in far greater ways than you
could ever imagine
Newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting a
future but the quantum model of reality
is is about causing an effect the moment
you start feeling abundant and worthy
you are generating wealth the moment
you're empowered and feel it you're
beginning to step towards your success
the moment you start feeling whole your
Healing Begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal now you're causing an
effect and I think that's the the
difference between living as a victim in
your world saying I am this way because
of this person or that thing or this
experience they made me think and feel
this way when you switch that around you
become a creator of your world and you
start saying my thinking and my feeling
is changing an outcome in my life and
now that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's in empowering it's me
in a different state It's My Future Self
is it meditation is it what does that
look like if you're not being defined by
a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
an emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive
so then why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's Close Our Eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have earplugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment if you can sit your body
down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here I'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then when you do that properly and
you're not eating anything or smelling
anything or tasting anything you're not
up experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will is getting
greater than the program and if you keep
doing this over and over again over and
over again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
gonna say well I'm gonna sit and the
moment that happens when the body is no
longer the mind when it finally
surrenders there's a liberation of
energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
ever
single thought we have or every sentence
we speak is an affirmation and it's
either positive or negative and it's
going out from us and it's creating our
experiences however when we talk about
doing affirmations what we're talking
about is making definite positive
statements to create something in our
life or to remove something in our life
you see if you stand there and say I
don't want this job or I don't want this
relationship or I don't want these hips
or I don't want whatever that does not
get you what you want that's what I call
fighting the negative and it doesn't do
anything but keep what you have that you
say you don't want however if you start
saying and doing affirmations that I
have a wonderful new job or I have this
most absolutely marvelous relationship
then you're beginning to create what it
is you do want affirmations are like
planting seeds
and if you think for a moment when you
put a seed in the ground you do not get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree that
seed goes in the ground and it has to
germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell and little
Roots begin to go down
and it gets nourishment from the Earth
and only then does the first Little
Chute come up through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they stomp on that
first Little Chute they don't give it a
chance to grow
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground and watering is it it
is like repeating your affirmations and
you just keep doing them and you keep
doing them and you keep doing them and
it doesn't matter whether you see the
results or you don't see the results and
sometimes it just takes time and too
many people will do affirmations for two
or three days and say see it doesn't
work
you know if
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that so if you begin
to do affirmations for yourself and I
think it's important that we do that on
a daily basis decide what you want
and begin to do positive statements in
present tense for what you want you
never want to say I will have or I'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future and remember if
you say I have a wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean that this is not a true statement
it means you are planting the seed that
will germinate and grow and become the
new apartment so you just keep doing it
no matter what where you are also if
you're leaving a situation if you're in
a job you don't like if you're in a
relationship you don't like if you're in
a a house you don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with love
interesting blessed with love where you
are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love if it's a
job release it with love to the next
person who will be delighted to have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship release that
person with love to happiness which is
Meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is Meaningful to
you if you expect to achieve your goals
if you expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true what I'm
about to explain to you is Mission
critical you must become a master at
visualization
now for those of you
that are like what the heck is she
talking about I did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo-woo spiritual
thing here
don't worry this is Mel Robbins there's
always science and research involved in
everything that I talk about so
visualization is a extraordinarily
powerful skill
and you may have heard of the law of
attraction
you may have heard of the word
visualization you may have heard of the
word manifesting I call it
um
seeing signs
so I'm a master at seeing positive signs
I am a master of creating coincidences I
have the world's most incredible luck
you want to know why because I
understand the science and the skill of
visualization
oh that you brain
brain is a filter your brain is
constantly looking for evidence and
that's good news it's good news when you
know how to use it to your advantage let
me explain
so your brain has a system in it here's
the technical term it's called the
reticular activating system
it is a network of neurons all up in
here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system it is a
filter system
it's basically a system that allows
certain information in your brain and it
blocks out other information
guess
programmed
filter
[Music]
and so did the people from your past and
so if you constantly feel like you're
unlovable guess what your reticular
activating system is going through the
day and it is going to point out every
single piece of evidence that confirms
that negative belief that you have if
your goal is to improve your self-worth
I want you to visualize
what your life looks like and how you're
going to feel
about yourself
when your self-worth has improved
here's how you're going to do it so
there's two things that you have to do
when it comes to visualization
you have to close your eyes
truly I know it sounds stupid but I want
you to close your eyes and I want you to
in your mind have a specific picture
of what it looks like in your life when
your self-worth has improved you're
going to see yourself speaking up at
work you're going to see yourself
talking more about your business you're
going to see yourself leaving bad
relationships you're going to see
yourself defining boundaries you're
going to see yourself going to the gym
you're going to see yourself uh taking
care of yourself and when you start to
visualize the image of that I want you
to consciously this is step two
consciously think of the positive
emotions that you're going to feel I'm
going to feel happy
I'm gonna feel proud I'm going to stand
taller I'm going to be so grateful that
I made this change
marrying the the specific picture oh
there I am there I am I'm I'm at work
and I'm raising my hand amazing I'm
sharing my idea there I am I'm getting a
promotion there I am asking for a raise
there I am I've just signed up another
customer to my business there I am I've
gone back to school I feel so good about
myself
when you do that here's what's actually
happening in your brain
this is the cool science part
you are training your brain to have a
totally different filter you see your
brain my brain it doesn't know the
difference between something that
actually happened to you
like the F you got in your test in 10th
Grade
and the things you imagine that are
happening to you
let me say that again
your brain doesn't know the difference
between the bad things that actually
happen to you
the real memories that you have and an
imagined memory that you're creating
your brain will experience you
visualizing going to the gym you
visualizing how happy you feel when you
do you visualizing asking for that raise
and getting it and how proud you're
going to feel your brain when you
visualize in the way that I'm teaching
you to it it encodes it as a real memory
and that's important because when you
encode it as a real memory it changes
the filter system that reticular
activating system and here's what we
know based on research the more you
visualize things number one
the greater your confidence is going to
be
the greater security you're going to
have about it and here's the really cool
thing
the more you do this with your goals you
wake up every day and you just visualize
for it takes 30 freaking seconds for
crying out loud you visualize having a
great day at school you visualize curing
your panic and how proud you're going to
be
what studies suggest and have proven is
that simply visualizing yourself doing
things actually develops the skill
and helps you improve the skills just as
if you were actually doing it the
problem with passion is that you and I
have bought into this massive fantasy
world where we think that passion is a
person or a place or a thing that
somehow like a needle in a stay Haz and
a needle in a haystack that you are
somehow just going to stumble into the
thing and you're going to find that one
person or you're going to find that one
thing that you're meant to do or you're
going to find that career and honestly
we gotta change the way that you think
about passion and purpose
before you will actually be able to
bring it into your life because the
truth is Passion isn't in a person it
isn't in a place and it isn't in a thing
it's something inside of you and when
you flip the definition of what passion
is and when you actually understand what
you're looking for when you say I want
to discover my passion
then you'll be able to create more of it
in your life I started thinking about
luck because there are for a long time
in my life I started to think that luck
was for other people that luck was just
one of those things that if you were
lucky enough to be born with luck you
won the lottery you got the job you
wanted your family got along and the
truth is there's a tremendous amount of
science behind luck that luck is
something that you can make for yourself
that you can become luckier based on the
things that you do and the things that
you think about and one of the things
about lucky people is a lot of lucky
people make their luck because they have
trained themselves to think
optimistically and one small trick that
you can use in your life that is free
you can do it today is when you go to
bed tonight before you go to sleep I
want you to write down one thing that
happened today that was good that's it
every night before you go to bed I want
you to write down one thing that
happened today that's good in fact let's
do it right now in the comments go to
the comments and tell me one thing that
has happened today that you can think of
that's good just one thing maybe you got
up on time maybe you didn't have traffic
today on the way to work maybe uh you
haven't fought with your kids this
morning maybe you got to the gym maybe
you woke up and for the first hour of
the day you didn't make yourself wrong
all of those things while they're really
little don't dismiss them because those
are things that are good and the reason
why I want you to start a practice where
every night before you go to bed or if
you don't want to do it at night do it
in the morning every night before you go
to bed write down one thing that
happened today that was good the reason
why you're doing this is you are
training yourself to start to spot the
good believe it or not training yourself
to start to look for the good in your
life fundamentally trains your mind away
from looking at the negative so that you
start seeing this thing that's positive
about your life versus that thing that's
negative about your life you're never
ever ever ever going to feel like doing
the things you need to do in order to
have what you want you're always going
to need to push yourself you're always
going to need to parent yourself so what
is the net advice on this what what is
the bottom line
the bottom line is no one's coming
no one
no one's coming to push you
no one's coming to tell you to turn the
TV off
no one's coming to tell you to get out
the door and exercise nobody's coming to
tell you to apply for that job that
you've always dreamed about nobody's
coming to write the business plan for
you it's up to you
and because you're only ever going to do
the things that you feel like doing
right now or that feel good right now
unless you understand that you've got to
parent yourself you got to push yourself
you're not going to make your dreams
come true you're just not
we're not wired that way you weren't
born that way you weren't that way when
you were growing up and you're certainly
not that way as an adult and there's a
tremendous amount of Liberation that
comes when you accept the fact that
you're always going to need to give
yourself a push the truth is if you want
control in your life if you want to make
things happen you have to be able to
expect that you're going to get a no and
do it anyway so what do I mean when I
say if you want control expect to know
well there's a couple things that I mean
by it number one if you're somebody that
gets paralyzed because you want things
to be perfect
perfectionism is a way that most of us
try to handle or mitigate or make sure
that we don't hear no we assume that if
we're perfect everything's going to go
okay and so we spend all of our energy
thinking about our dating profile or
thinking about the business plan or
thinking about how to make things
perfect and the reason why we do that is
we're terrified to hear no we're
terrified to put something out there
that's not perfect because if it's not
perfect you might get a no
um one of the better ways to handle this
is to actually expect a no you know I
saw the most incredible quote by our
friend faustina
over in Australia she's very famous BJ
and friend of ours from Australia and
she put up the most amazing quote and
I'm going to get it totally wrong but
it's something like this you have to be
yourself
because
how else are the people who are looking
for you gonna find you and I think
particularly when it comes to dating
what we tend to do is we are so afraid
of being rejected by anybody out there
that we try to be somebody that we're
not that we put out a fake improved or
what we think is improved version of
ourselves in order to not hear no and
most of us pretend to be somebody that
we're not When We Fear rejection when we
believe that how we are who we are isn't
good enough and so that's why it's so
important for you to understand that you
have to be willing to hear a no you have
to be willing to hear a no from the
wrong people so that the people that are
looking for you can find you so that the
people who want to be part of your
business can be part of your business if
you're putting a fake person out there
or a pretend perfect person out there
because you think that's gonna that's
gonna save you from rejection
you're actually screwing yourself over
you're not a procrastinator you have a
habit of procrastinating
big difference
because if it's a habit I can teach you
to use science to break it
you see all habits have three parts
there's a trigger and in the case of
procrastination the trigger is always
stress
then there's a pattern you repeat and in
the case of procrastination it is to
avoid doing something and then there's a
reward you get a little stress relief
the only way to break a habit you guys
is not to deal with the triggers
you're never going to get rid of the
stress in your life but you can 100
percent change your pattern of avoiding
work
so next time that you're in a situation
where you feel yourself hesitate you
spent way too much time checking out the
highlights from last night's scores what
you're going to do is you're going to go
up I must be stressed out about
something acknowledge the stress then go
54321 I want you to count to yourself
because I want you to interrupt The
Habit that's stored here and I want you
to awaken your prefrontal cortex then I
want you to just work just for five
minutes the reason why I want you to
only work for five minutes is because
your problem isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding I just need
you to start and here's the other cool
thing
we know based on Research that if we can
get you to start 80 percent of you are
going to keep going do it anyway is a
mindset trick that you can use when you
start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five second rule so
you have said to yourself okay I'm going
to talk to my boss today about that
thing that I've been avoiding talking to
them about or maybe you've said
something like I'm gonna go to the gym
today or tomorrow or whatever and then
the moment comes where you've got to
have that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag and leave your desk and
go to the gym and what always happens
you don't feel like it
I bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that I'm not
going to have a drink tonight
and then guess what happens when you get
home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink and so here's
what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway
pushed me to realize and to recognize
that there are a lot of moments when
there are things in my life that I
really want to do
I need to do
I should do but when the moment comes I
don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside I said I would go
for a short run I don't feel like it I'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning I'm tired it's cold
I laid out my yoga clothes but now I
don't feel like it what do I do I do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
I'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what I'm gonna do it anyway
the one person that is diminishing your
ability to make these dreams a reality
is you
because when you state your dream this
is what happens you state it and then
all of a sudden you're present to how
far away you are from it and when you
see the distance between where you are
and where you want to go the direction
that your dream requires you to walk in
you're going to get present to the Gap
and that scares us that's where fear
comes into play and you start to think
of all the reasons why you don't deserve
it you start to think of all the reasons
why you can't do it all that you have to
do in order to start to pursue your
dreams is take small actions every day
that align your life in that direction
so what does that mean if you want to
play guitar professionally it means that
you start playing Guitar more it means
that you sign up for Open Mic nights it
means that you go back to class if if
that's something that interests you you
see your dreams will happen either
because of you or in spite of you they
don't happen because of other people
they happen because of you and what you
do
the second you have The Bravery to state
that dream now are you going to create
it or are you going to diminish it in
your mind here's your new definition of
passion passion is simply energy that's
all that it is okay
passion is what you feel when you are
energized and excited about what you're
doing okay I want you to think about
that for a minute I want you to think
about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate about something
okay and why don't you in the comments
tell me where are you watching from and
tell me about a moment in time when you
felt incredibly passionate about what
you were doing about where you were
about the people that you were with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to really investigate passion
is energy this is what you're going to
discover those moments when you are
super passionate like I'm sure my kids
would write down when they're doing
community theater with all their friends
I would write down whenever I'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team I'm incredibly energized whenever
I'm doing group exercise stuff climbing
a mountain doing a 5K race doing some
sort of walkathon I'm incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm
um doing some sort of creative project
incredibly energized by that whenever
I'm working with our video team
incredibly energized by that whenever I
am coaching someone or giving advice I
am incredibly energized by that and so
what I want you to understand is that if
you look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt passion I'm
being very deliberate in how I'm talking
this morning on coffee talk because
passion is a huge topic for so many of
you and you've been so focused on trying
to figure out what job is going to make
me uh passionate what job is my passion
what is my purpose on the earth I'm
going to tell you what your purpose on
Earth is right now your purpose on Earth
is to figure out how to align your life
so that you feel more energized and
excited by it that's it and it begins
with you following the energy and
following your natural enthusiasm you're
not going to think your way to Passion
you can't think your way to finding
something that you feel in your heart it
doesn't work that way you got to feel
your way into it it's inside of you do
you understand there's no passion out
there somewhere the passion is in here
and so what you have to do first is
you've got to stop thinking that you're
going to find it somewhere and you've
got to realize that passion is about
unlocking something that's all in you
you
born your home and then we go to
kindergarten and then you go to first
grade and then you go to second grade
and then you go to third grade and then
you go to fourth grade and then you go
to fifth grade and then you go to middle
school and then you go to high school
and then there's pressure to go to
college or to a tech school or to do
something else and then you get your job
and then you're in your job and then you
meet somebody and then you get married
and then you're supposed to buy the
house and then you're supposed to have
the kids and maybe get the dog before
the kids or after the kids but then you
have a second kid and then you have the
0.5 kid because most of us do 2.5 kids
and then we get and then we get the the
home equity line and then we put the
kitchen addition on and then we I mean
it's like our entire lives are set out
in this linear progression as people
Chase
the Dream the next
and particularly
for
those of us who are triggered by the
fear of losing control
it's only natural
to Anchor
your feeling of being in control to
chasing the next thing
and so not only are we all socialized to
believe that we're supposed to climb
this ladder we're supposed to do things
in a linear progression we're supposed
to
get to the next thing we've also been
marketed to
foreign
by society that will be happier if we
have a new car we'll be happier if we
have a better dishwasher we'll be
happier if we have the skin lotion
that's got the almond scent
and we're also psychologically anchoring
our sense of control and our sense of
Happiness on achieving those things and
what you're experiencing is no different
than what millions and millions and
millions of us experience
and that's that emptiness that you feel
when you buy the lotion that smells like
almond butter
and it doesn't make you happy
or you get the promotion
and you
have an extra hundred bucks in your
paycheck after taxes and it means you
can buy the 14 Chardonnay not the ten
dollar shortened Chardonnay and it
doesn't make you happy
and the reason why
is
the I'll be happy when life the chase
the carrot life the get to the next
thing life
that form of Happiness requires you to
be driving
let's use the car analogy again to be
going 60 miles an hour at all times
and happiness is achieved through a
different formula
it happens when you're sitting at the
light and you're idle when you're in the
moment doing things that make you happy
and that's being with people that you
care about it's engaging in experiences
that make you happy and it's working on
things that are important to you what
you believe about yourself is the only
thing that matters at the end of the day
no matter how much outside affirmations
you get or other people telling you that
you're amazing if you don't believe in
your heart that you are amazing it won't
none of that will last like you've ever
gone to an event or you ever made a
video or created something or you're
hanging out with a friend and they tell
you how amazing you are and that feels
good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades that stuff doesn't
last you don't have somebody being a
cheerleader for you every day showing up
in your bedroom saying hooray go do this
you're amazing right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never going to love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
well okay so that's that's a lot of
words how do you actually go off and do
it
I think for me this is why I believe
that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our
worst enemies it's rough I actually
think it's great to be your own worst
critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we are very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives they're barely
hanging on most people are barely
hanging on
barely hanging on to what we're doing we
we can post all these great things on
Instagram or wherever and make it look
like we're enjoying our life but most
people are barely hanging on the people
who are judging you for your life and
telling you that you suck hate their own
lives they are barely hanging on so how
do we get through it well yes we can be
harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself more you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masking
and insecurity
right it's like those people who uh
have you ever seen those memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything and now he's like he doesn't
care you know just walking on a T-shirt
and some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masking and
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk her out and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
came on you would have to you would have
to move right it doesn't mean that
you're up and like dancing through the
whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today
yeah it's but I demand excellence and
that that starts with music because I
don't have I don't want to spend a lot
of time trying to get into the right
state of mind I can command it whenever
I want just by putting on the right song
so be in tension with your music and the
lyrics being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rocking uh
I'll walk to Tim Hortons usually get a
coffee
you know this costs two bucks two
something so I only had you know what's
the what's the best money I spend every
year well it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and I'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and I'm thinking about what I
want to accomplish today and the lives
that I want to serve and the people I
want to help and and what I'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brandedics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate that
means it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe walks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation in somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things the beautiful
thing about monk life is half the day is
self and half the day is service that's
how you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is odd
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected I know
exactly whereas when my morning routine
is weakened I feel weak and so for me
the morning routine as I get strategic
about it there's two principles you have
to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years
and so when you find a space in your
home and even if you've got like I lived
in a 500 square foot apartment in New
York four years ago and I just had a
tiny Corner which I dedicated to my
sacred practices so if you you don't
have to have a big home to do this you
don't have to be wealthy to do this you
can find just a corner in your home that
you dedicate as your meditation space or
your reflection space so first thing
location has energy second thing time
has memory and this is something that
people underestimate when you do
something at the same time every day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you will feel hungry you will feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercising
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for
practical steps to reprogram your mind
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Step One
manifesting according to science you
gotta claim what you want and tell the
truth so let's say that step one I want
to train for and I want to complete the
New York City marathon that is a bucket
list item for me